if you think you may have been exposed
to someone who is like 19
contact your health care
provider you can also take these
steps at home and stay away
from people you live with to
avoid passing cob to them and 19
get tested  from kobe 19 monitor your
symptoms if you have any of the
following emergency warning symptoms
seek immediate medical attention
shortness of breath
persistent chest pain or pressure
confusion inability to wake or
stay awake
pale gray or bluish skin lips or nail beds
depends on the  your
skin tone if you have kobe 19 your
healthcare provider will talk to you about the
best treatment options the us
food and drug administration
has approved a drug
known by the brand name torino
to treat kobe 19 your  Your
health care provider may prescribe this
medication to treat your copper 19  and
help you get better your
health care provider may also
recommend that you take over-the-counter medications such
as acetaminophen or
ibuprofen to reduce fever and
help you feel better it is important to
drink plenty of water to stay
hydrated in some cases your
health care provider may recommend
that you  receive intravenous fluids
to stay hydrated it is also
important
to get enough rest this will
help your body fight the virus
if you are very sick your
healthcare provider may recommend that you
get treatment for kobe 19 in a
hospital in some people
kobe 19 may  damage the heart blood
vessels kidneys brain
skin eyes and gastrointestinal organs
if you have any of these complications you
may be given medicines to
treat them for example some people
may be given blood thinners to
prevent or treat blood clots
remember that the best way to
pr  to protect yourself is to avoid getting or
spreading kobe 19 some things you can
do to keep yourself and
others healthy include the following:
stay 6 feet away from
people who do not live in your home
wear a mask over your nose and mouth
avoid places  with lots of people
wash your hands often cover
your nose and mouth if you cough or sneeze
clean frequently touched surfaces
get a
flu shot get a come 19 shot let's review what
we just discussed and go over
some of the key points if you think  who
may have been exposed to cove' 19
contact your health
care provider your health care provider
will talk to you about the best ways to
treat kobe 19 if you are very sick your
health care provider may
recommend that you get treatment for
kobe 19 at a  hospital the best way
to protect yourself is to avoid getting or
spreading kobe 19
[Music]